flug lufthansa 11 52 im landeanflug auf
palma de mallorca die baleareninsel ist
nach monatelangen corona beschränkungen
zu einem traumziel deutscher urlauber
geworden wegen der großen nachfrage ist
auf den zweistündigen flug einer boeing
747 unterwegs der jumbo fliegt
normalerweise nur langstreckenziele in
asien oder in nordamerika an flugkapitän
richard leitlinien prüft in palma
triebwerke und fahrwerk auf schäden
da waren waren
das sind wieder unterwegs seien würden
dann kommen die passagiere für den
rückflug nach frankfurt an bord co-pilot
felix ebner bereitet den start vor auf
dem blick auf malerische küsten musste
er anderthalb jahre verzichten wegen der
pandemie wurden piloten kaum gebraucht
ich hatte jetzt durch corona
zwangsläufig nach hause in kurzarbeit
von 15 monaten das sehr sehr lange zeit
ist so lang war ich noch nie aus der
fliegerei raus das ist ganz besonderes
gefühl wieder an bord zu sein sein
erster flug nach der zwangspause findet
quasi unter aufsicht statt schulungs
kapitän richard weiterhin überprüft ob
noch alle handgriffe sitzen auch wenn
der co pilot bereits seit 17 jahren
fliegt in dem moment wo ich hier sitze
und meine funktion ausüben muss dieselbe
qualität und sicherheit gewährleistet
sein wie vor den 15 monaten pause
corona hin oder her auch für die
flugbegleiterinnen hinten in der
maschine hat die pandemie einiges
verändert deutschlands größte airline
hat touristen als neue zielgruppe
entdeckt bei geschäftsreisen durch
videokonferenzen seltener geworden sind
sollen urlauber jetzt in umsatz sichern
und die arbeitsplätze
vielleicht ein zweimal im jahr nur haben
andere fragen manchmal natürlich auch
flughaben copilot felix ebner hat ein
paar tage zuvor die landung in frankfurt
durchgespielt im simulator
hier musste der erfahrene pilot unter
den strengen augen eines controllers
gefährliche situationen meistern
erst danach darf er wieder passagiere
befördern das funktioniert erstaunlich
gut man setzt sich dahin und es ist
trotzdem ist es gut erst mal im
simulator das zu üben im richtigen
flugzeug von mallorca sind felix ebner
und schulungs kapitän richard weil ihn
wieder in frankfurt gelandet in zwei
tagen schon steht der nächste flug auf
dem dienstplan in die usa